uh
can we talk about phosphine a little bit
um so you mentioned it's a pretty
i love fossee what's your twitter handle
that's like dr phosphene
it's dr phosphine yes you will be
surprised here it wasn't taken already i
could just i just grabbed it
didn't have to buy it off anyone yeah
so what uh what is it what's phosphine
you already mentioned it's
pretty toxic and um troublesome
what and outside
so maybe what are some things that uh
make it interesting chemically and why
is it a good sign of life uh
one is present in the atmosphere like
you've described in your paper
uh aptly titled the phosphine as a
biosignature gas in
exoplanet atmospheres i suppose you
wrote that paper before venus
i did yes it did and no one cared
you know in that paper i said something
like if we find phosphine on
any terrestrial planet can only mean
life and everyone's like yeah that
sounds about right let's go
and then venus shows up and i was like
are you sure i'm like okay i was sure
before i was sure now that it's
right here um i'm less sure
now that my claims are being tested
so phosphine fossum is a fascinating
molecule so it's
shaped like a pyramid with a phosphorus
up top and then three hydrogens
it's actually quite a simple molecule in
many ways and
you know it's the most popular elements
in the universe
carbon hydrogen nitrogen oxygen
phosphorus sulfur
when you add hydrogen to them it makes
quite simple quite famous
uh molecules you know you do it to
oxygen you get water
you do it to carbon you get methane you
do it to nitrogen you get ammonia
these are all molecules people have
heard of but you do it to phosphorus
you get phosphine people haven't heard
of phosphine because
it's not really popular on earth um we
really shouldn't find it anywhere
on earth because it is extremely toxic
to life
it interacts with oxygen metabolism and
everything you know and love uses oxygen
metabolism
and it interacts fatally so it kills in
several very imaginative and very
macabre ways
so it was used as a chemical warfare
agent in the first world war and
most recently by isis so really bad
most life avoids it even life that might
not avoid it so life that doesn't use
oxygen metabolism anaerobic life
still has to put crazy amounts of effort
into making it it's a really difficult
molecule to make thermodynamically
speaking it's really difficult to make
that phosphorus want to be together with
that hydrogen
so it's horrible everyone avoids it when
they're not avoiding it
it's extremely difficult to make you
would have to put energy
in sacrifice energy to make it and if
you did go through all that trouble
and made it it gets um reacted with the
radicals in the atmosphere
and gets destroyed so we shouldn't find
it anywhere and yet we do
it's kind of weird molecule that seems
to
be made by life and we don't even know
why life clearly finds a use for it
it's not the only molecule the life is
willing to sacrifice energy to make but
we don't know how or why life is even
making it so absolutely mysterious
absolutely deadly smells horrifically
when it's made it produces other kind of
diphosphines and
it's been reported as smelling like
garlicky fishy death
uh once someone referred to it as
smelling like the let me see if i
remember the the rancid diapers of the
spawn of satan
oh very nice yeah very very vivid and so
you're a poet after all i didn't i
didn't call it that someone else did
and so it's just this horrific molecule
but it is produced by life
we don't know why and when it is
produced by life is done with enormous
sacrifice
and the universe does not sacrifice life
sacrifices and so it's this strange
contradictory molecule that we should
all be avoiding and yet
seems to be an almost unambiguous sign
of life on rocky planets
okay can we dig into that a little bit
so what on rocky planets
what uh is there biological mechanisms
that can produce it and
is there is there you said the
why is unclear why life might produce it
but is there an understanding of what
kind of mechanisms might be able to
produce it
this very difficult to produce molecule
we don't know yet
the enzymatic pathways of fossum
production by life
are not yet known this is not actually
as surprising as it might sound
i think something like 80 of all the
natural products that we know of so we
know biology makes them
we don't know how it is much easier to
know life produces something because you
can put you know bacteria in a petri
dish
and then watch and then that gas is
produced you go oh life made it
that actually happened with phosphene
but that's much easier to do of course
than figuring out what is the exact
metabolic pathway within that life form
that created the this uh molecule so
we don't know yet phosphene is really
understudied um no one had really heard
of it until
nowish what you were presenting is the
fact that life produces
phosphate not the the process by which
it produces fasting
is there an urgency now like if you were
to try to understand the mechanisms
the what did you call enzymatic pathways
that produce phosphine how difficult is
that of a problem to crack
it's really difficult if i'm not
mistaken even
you know the scent of truffles obviously
a billion dollar industry
huge deal until quite recently it wasn't
known exactly how those
scents those molecules that create this
incredible smell were produced and this
is a billion dollar industry
as you can imagine there is no such
pressure there's no phosphine lobby or
anything
that would push for this research but i
hope someone picks picks it up and
does it and it isn't crazy because
we know that fossum is really hard to
make we know it's really hard for it to
happen accidentally you know even
lightning and volcanoes that can produce
small amounts of phosphine
it's extremely difficult for even these
extreme processes to make it
so it's not really surprising that only
life can do it because life
is willing to make things at a cost
so maybe on the topic of phosphine
what uh again you're you've gotten
yourself into trouble with that i'm
going to ask you all these like
high-level poetic questions i apologize
no i would love it
okay what when did you first
fall in love with phosphine
it wasn't love at first sight it was
somewhere between
a long relationship and stockholm
syndrome
yeah yeah when when i first started my
phd
i knew i wanted to learn about molecular
spectra and how to simulate it
i thought it was really outrage
outrageous that we as a species
couldn't detect molecules remotely we
didn't have this perfect catalog ready
of the molecular fingerprint of every
molecule we may want to find in the
universe
and something as basic as phosphine the
fact that we didn't really know how it
interacted with light
and so we couldn't detect it properly
you know in the galaxy
just i was so indignant and so initially
i just
started working on phosphine because
people hadn't before
and i thought we should know what
phosphine looks like
that was it and then i read every paper
that's ever been published about
phosphine
it was quite easy because there aren't
that many
and that's when i started learning about
where we had already founded
in the universe and what it meant um i
started finding out quite how little we
know about it
and why and it was only when i joined
mit and i started talking to biochemists
that the that have been became clear
that fossen wasn't just
weird and special and understudied and
disgusting
it was all these things for oxygen
loving life
and it was the anaerobic world that
would welcome phosphine and that's when
the idea of looking for it on other
planets became crystallized
because oxygen is very powerful and very
important on earth but
that's not necessarily going to be the
case on other exoplanets most planets
are oxygen pole
overwhelmingly most planets are oxygen
poor
and so finding the sign of life that
would be welcomed by
everything that would live without
oxygen on earth seemed so cool
[Laughter]
and but ultimately the project that
first was born of the idea that you want
to find that molecular
fingerprint of any of a
molecule so and that this is just one
example
and that's connected
to then looking at for looking for that
fingerprint elsewhere in a remote way
and obviously that then at that time
were exoplanets already when you were
doing your phd and you by those should
say your phd
thesis was it was all on phosphine 100
with a little bit of pneumonia i have a
chapter that i i did
where i talked about phosphine and
ammonia so i
got it but no phosphine was very much my
thesis um but at that that
at that time when you're writing it
there's already a sense that exoplanets
are out there
and uh we might be able to be looking
for bio signatures for
um on those exoplanets pretty much so i
finished my phd in 2015
we found the first exoplanets in the
kind of mid to late 90s
so exoplanets were known it was known
that some had atmospheres
and from there it's not a big jump to
think well if some have atmospheres some
of those might be
habitable and some of those may be
inhabited
you